8 et bonsoir monsieur cortellino lance
aux mains souffrions jusqu'à quel point
la crise a changé les perspectives
immobilières au canada dont quelques
instants vous donner des prévisions
annuelles très intéressante sur les
divers centres du pays
est ce qu'au savoir ce que lorsqu'on des
couples l'année 2020 dans une période de
près qu'au vu des postes-clés dans vos
changements avant un changement de
dynamique sur le marché donc par exemple
on parle que du marché de montréal
on avait un marché très actif en termes
de mises en chantier des ventes sur le
marché leurs ventes les prix atteignait
des sommets et donc nous tu étais de
cette crise causée par le cos vite
prenant que les mises en chantier
étaient plus forts les ventes centriste
n'aurait pas reculer et vous dire
quelques instants pour montréal on
aurait une hausse de prix en 2020 malgré
du club il met le procès d'oscar été
plus forte sans que vais donc ont eu un
impact vraiment de momentum disons
tournée suite à la crise du col vide
ça dépend des centres comme montréal au
mans c'est vraiment un ralentissement de
la cadence au troisième trimestre de
2020 dont je l'appelle l'état environ
par la suite les choses devaient
reprendre que graduellement dans notre
scénario optimiste mais par contre on
voit quand même que un taux de chômage
élevé une perte de confiance des
consommateurs
ça vient affecter le marché mobilier
dans plusieurs centres dont montréal qui
était littéralement surchauffe en début
d'année mais je suis quand même étonné
par lee prix vraiment l'évolution des
prix on comprend que dans l'ouest les
prix vont baisser mais dans l'est à
toronto et à montréal on voit des
hausses de prix dans une année où on dit
qu'on est frappé par la crise comme
jamais on a été frappé comment expliquer
que les prix puissent encore augmenter
je voudrais que son regard de l'année
2019 par exemple à montréal on en
interne avec un prix moyen de 4 cents à
8000 $ et au premier trimestre 2008
marche était très actif donc lorsqu'on
garder le rythme des poux premier
trimestre on est à 445 1000 $ donc loin
du 400 m haies dollars jusqu'en 2019
et donc même s'il anticipe un
ralentissement des prix de 8 à 10% au
cours des prochains mois mais le début
d'année et le volume était tellement
important début d'année en terme de prix
que ça va venir en plus ils ont sauvé la
données annuelles des enfants sauf que
2020 va sortir avec une hausse de prix à
comparer à 2019 et aussi certains comme
ottawa toronto un des marchés où sur une
tête l'offre était quand même
relativement restreinte selon de
propriété domaine sur le lancement des
ventes avec une offre illimitée les
conditions de marchés juteux sont moins
affectés ce qu'ils font en sorte qu' on
a des prix sont moins juste à la baisse
que dans certains centres comme quand le
rythme le chapiteau est encore plus
important avec la colline et ça fait en
sorte qu'on ait des différences
régionales est important le marché ne
s'est pas effondré ce lundi faut dire
que le marché son regard des données
d'avril et mai ces dernières données
réelles que longtemps après le début du
confinement mois de mars on regarde les
données quand même le rythme d'activité
beaucoup ralenti mais les marchés de
pratiquement fermée à cette période là
on peut pas construire aussi en termes
de transactions c'est très utile
d'acheter une propriété avec un courtier
immobilier c'était virtuel où plus que
jamais à la propriété en vente sur le
marché pour diverses raisons center bon
par exemple lorsqu'on regarde les
données de ventes ce marché la revente
au premier trimestre à 2020 ou l'un de
55000 vente par année donc si le premier
trimestre avait été représentatif de
l'année au complet on a retourné 2020
avec 55 mille vente qui boivent plus que
c'est quand même elle enregistre en 2019
mais son regard des données d'avril et
mai on représente non seulement un
rythme annuel de 24000 transaction donc
on voit que la fermeture du marché un
grand impact
mon anticipe que ça va reprendre au
cours des prochains mois et que quand on
reprend terme en tout cas qu'une baisse
de 3 à 8% donc nous tu étais de la coved
encore une fois les ventes centriste les
mises en chantier les prix à lacaune eu
des volumes des hausses plus importantes
qu'est ce qu'on avait prévu mais étant
donné qu'on ait eu cette crise là le
momentum la cadence va diminuer jusqu'à
la fin de l'été pour ensuite reprendre
graduellement la vitesse de cette
reprise va vous rendez pas on un peu de
toutes les occasions de deuxième vice de
traitement vaccin reprise l'emploi et
tout ça donc ce sera à suivre au cours
des deux prochains mois mais cruellement
à la la on appris dans les dernières
semaines que 15 % des détenteurs
d'hypothèques au canada ont eu recours
ou sur site six mois offerts par les
grandes banques
est ce que ça pourrait se traduire par
autant de reprises de finance en quelque
sorte dont je crois pouvoir on peut pas
encore un calcul direct de nombre de
personnes qui ont reporté leurs
paiements hypothécaires avec les
reprises possible donc on sait que
l'économie est en train de reprendre
graduellement
donc les reprises d'emploi donc les gens
pas retrouvé leurs sources de revenus
cadre du helmand aussi des aides
gouvernementales qui ont été allongés
qui est un signe positif pour aider les
ménages qui sont très problèmes de
paiements hypothécaires pour le moment
en comptant le disais bon le vol
impactent directement serait vraiment
cours des prochains mois on a déjà vu
qu'en mai l'emploi avait commencé à
reprendre au québec dans la région de
montréal on en cite quand je vois aussi
la clim auto de déconfinement qui
s'allège l'emploi va continuer à
augmenter donc au cours de prochains
mois si l'emploi reprend plus de vigueur
ça va pas mal probablement aux gens de
reprendre leurs paiements hypothécaires
et de ne pas avoir ce 15% là en terme de
reprise aura au bowling est-ce qu'on
assiste ou est-ce qu'on va assister à
une hausse du taux d'inoccupation dans
le logement
très bonne question on sait qu'à
montréal depuis quelques années on
construit énormément d'appartements
locatifs
on prévoit cette année à peu près dix
mille nouveaux appartements locatifs qui
vont s'ajouter aux marchés du jamais vu
depuis très très longtemps et en même
temps un un facteur très important que
la demande locative c'était la migration
donc les immigrants et ils résident mon
permanent donc est ce un étranger
travailleurs internationaux et aussi
demandeurs d'asile et ça ça n'est
vraiment gonflé de marchetti beaucoup
deux dernières années à montréal et ça
et fluence la demande locative faisait
chuter le taux d'inoccupation qu'est-ce
que les dernières données nous indique
le nombre d'immigrants de janvier à
avril au québec a baissé de 26% 94% se
marre le mois d'avril
on pense que mes joueurs savent est
aussi très fait annuler les restrictions
aux frontières et les résidents non
permanents la donnée de janvier à mars
2020 mais c'est déjà en baisse de 40%
par rapport à janvier à mars 2019 et on
peut anticiper qu'en avril et mes
joueurs sont encore si des mois très
faible cote étudiants internationaux
travers temporaire et tout le reste
donc si le solde migratoire diminue car
une façon importante au cours des
prochains mois cette année la demande
locative vont être affectés négativement
et avec cette offre sérieuse soit marché
on peut ainsi peut-être une légère
détente sur le marché locatif
montréalais pour l'année 2020
intéressant très intéressante analyse
francis cortellino merci beaucoup merci
à vous ment soirée bonne soirée